nos están dando cuatro ecuaciones
diferentes y cada una de ellas tiene un
espacio vacío que tenemos que llenar
nunca en cada uno de estos espacios
tenemos que poner el número que falta
entonces pues vamos a hacerlo uno por
uno vamos a empezar con esta ecuación de
aquí del lado izquierdo tenemos uno más
4 es igual a es decir 1 + 4 es y pues
uno más cuatro es igual a 5 gray 14 es 5
sí tenemos 4 y le sumamos 1 nos quedan 5
entonces ya terminamos con esta porque
uno más 4 es igual a 5 nuclear y
entonces vamos con la siguiente ecuación
que nos dice que 4 más
alguna cosa es igual a 5 pero pues aquí
arriba
acabamos de averiguar que 14 es igual a
entonces pues 41 es igual a 5
así es que podemos poner por aquí que
cuatro más uno es igual a cinco y
observa ya tenemos la ecuación cuatro
más uno es lo mismo que cinco y este
signo de igual eso es lo que significa
que lo que tenemos en la izquierda es lo
mismo que lo que tenemos en la derecha
pero bueno vamos con la siguiente
ecuación tenemos que el espacio más 2 es
igual a 5 y que número 2 es igual a 5
bueno pues sabemos que tres más dos es
igual a 565 es igual a tres más dos y
ahora vamos para acá pero aquí ya
tenemos la respuesta porque como vimos
por aquí tres más dos es igual a cinco
entonces pues tres más dos es igual a
cinco todo demostrar estas respuestas
que estuvieron muy bien y seguir
haciendo ejercicios y ahora nos salió un
ejercicio que tiene restas entonces
cuánto es 9 -3 acá y si tenemos 9 cosas
y le quitamos tres cosas cuántas cosas
nos quedan
si tenemos nueve cosas y quitamos tres
lo que nos queda son seis cosas entonces
nueve menos tres es igual a seis y luego
me es menos el espacio es igual a seis
entonces cuántas cosas le tengo que
quitar a diez para que nos quedan seis
cosas bueno pues si tenemos diez cosas y
le quitamos cuatro nos quedan seis cosas
y por acá algo menos uno es igual a seis
y bueno pues tenemos que siete menos uno
es igual a seis y finalmente ocho menos
algo es igual a seis entonces cuánto le
tenemos que quitar a 8
para llegar a 6 bueno pues si tenemos 8
y le quitamos 1 llegamos a 7 pero si
tenemos 8 y le quitamos 2 llegamos a 6
entonces 8 menos 2 es igual a 6